finally this is the the 2010-2011
biennial report this is a report in
which I tried to track every single
place that I went over the course of the
year and i also tried to tackle who I
was with so that I could say with my
girlfriend these are the places that we
like to go with my best friend this is
where we go when I'm in New York these
are my habits when it melts who are
these are my other habits and you can
see these all sort of overlaid in this
document where blue represent 2010 and
the magenta represents 2011 and then
they're overlaid in different different
manners with pie charts evaluating the
different behaviors and and here's a
detail so this is with my girlfriend you
can see in the left at California on the
right-hand side that's New York City so
there's a yarn connecting all these
places and you can see from the purple
ones where the overlap occurs which were
the places that we went to over both
years so this is one of the downsides of
hoarding this is what your calendar
comes to look like when you're trying to
track everything you eat and drink
everywhere you go and every one you're
with so it's kind of color coded and I
did this for two years and then I let it
go so these are my thoughts on hoarding
you know you can you can achieve a high
degree of completeness with this but the
costs are high and in trying to create
these documents I'm trying to come up
with methodologies that don't interfere
in the life I'm trying to record so I
constantly get the question like how
much do you track how much time you
spend tracking which for me is a sort of
recursive problem and I don't want to
think about it
but I'm all is I don't even do any
analysis until the end of the year I
want to Italia us all up and then look
back on the behavior